i don't know how much i want to tell
this i want to hear it even more now um
when i was in high school i was dating a
girl uh we were together for four years
was what's her name what's her name i'm
i'm gonna keep that one to myself for
now
somewhere in the middle of our
relationship like a year two years in
three i don't know somewhere in there we
had made out fooled around a bit and we
hadn't had sex
but i remember a couple days later she's
like hey um i need you to get something
for me i was like okay yeah sure what is
it and she's like i need you to get a
pregnancy test i was like excuse me
she's like
my period's late it's never late i just
please and so i i'm freaking out because
i'm like we haven't even
does it work can that is it possible i
don't know i didn't have a car i don't
think at this point because i remember i
remember i had to ride my bike to kmart
oh no
i had to ride my bike to kmart and i
like pull up i park it on the sidewalk
and i go in and i have no idea what i'm
doing dude i'm just freaking out yeah
and i walk up and i mean when i was
younger i i don't know if i still had
the afro at this point but i looked like
an [ __ ] yeah uh and i'm walking
around looking for employees and i find
something like where are your um fancy
tests
are they like excuse me i was like yeah
i my mom needs a pregnancy
i said it and i was like oh [ __ ]
and they're like uh okay uh
not believing me at all oh wow well yeah
my mom needs a pregnancy test so they
leave me over there here you go and
there's like i don't know how many
options there were at the time but there
were options and i was just like ah
which one and they're like well i don't
know
like they look at me like i don't
[ __ ] know what kind of pregnancy this
too
how pregnant might she be so i'm like
looking looking i'm pregnant it's your
mother a bunch of guys just like i don't
know
yeah i had to wait in line for all the
other high school dudes waiting to buy
their pregnancy tests their bikes were
also parked out for their moms yeah
[Laughter]
in ohio no they come up there like i
gotta get that guy's mom a practice
t-test
yeah me too
[Laughter]
so i buy one i mean i had i'm not gonna
talk about the route i had to go on but
it was like a decent bite i'm just on my
bike riding home with a bag a kmart bag
with a pregnancy test in it just like
sweating bullets from stressful
thinking about the fact like what if
that guy knows my mom
i remember i was like just please don't
run anybody please don't worry anybody
of course my mom's like in the driveway
as i get there like oh what'd you do
what were you doing at kmart's like i'm
just grabbing a treat
for some reason i don't know why my
mental image but you have training
wheels on your bike
like a little hat with that spinny
propeller on the top of it i got a
little horn i squeezed
[Laughter]
mom
what are all these kids doing lined up
outside your house
sorry mom but you know we all had to buy
you a pregnancy
spoiler alert after my ex uh used it
turns out she wasn't pregnant and all's
good period started like the next day
can't believe it
yeah i'd like to start by thanking my
mom for existing so i could buy that
pregnancy test under a very good uh good
fake story the reason you were born
my whole life was for this one moment
cruising on my bicycle to buy a
pregnancy test